[Music]
you got in some trouble recently not too
long ago in New Zealand and I don't know
how a comedian here in the states gets
in trouble in New Zealand what did you
do here's what happened Conan I wasn't
in New Zealand per se when I was on my
showing ups I'm obsessed with sharks I
love sharks I love when they kill people
they're not the part most people love no
but it's the part they get excited about
yes you know I mean and I like 30 people
died a year from shark attacks but like
a hundred million sharks died from
people every year so on my show I
thought would be funny and it was if
when a guy got killed by a shark we
would do a thing called shark party we
would have like I'd like I'd have
dancers come out and this guy from New
Zealand got eaten by a shark so my
garden guys this guy got eaten let's
celebrate
I had girls come out dressed like in
like shark dresses dancing with me
and then I had a girl come out like a
shark mascot outfit and she'd give me a
lap dance and it was great when I say it
it sounds bad but when you see it you're
like oh amazing
everyone in America their people were
cool with it here but then they took the
media in New Zealand took the clip and
they showed it around to New Zealanders
and they got furious they were really
upset and there was like a backlash I
think the problem was was in New Zealand
they don't know who I am you know I mean
like if Andy got eaten by a shark if
Andy was killed by a shark and I did
that even you would be like I'm sorry my
friends dead but that's classic Jeselnik
right that's exactly what I would say
yeah I miss my good friend who I've
known for forever yeah but yeah classic
Jeff it's a great bit right up his alley
yeah but in New Zealand they got so mad
that they they were like death threats
for me online sure and then they someone
posted my mom and dad's address and
phone number online which was really
tough so I had to happen change their
phone number and I had to call the
police department of my local police
department and tell them to watch out
for my mom and dad which was crazy
because I call them and I'm like hey you
need to protect my parents and then like
well why what I have to do that I'm like
well I have a TV show and I did a shark
dance about a guy who died and now you
need to go protect me that I go well let
me get this straight
what's the name of the show and I'm like
the Jeselnik offense if they like when's
it on I'm like Tuesdays at 10:30 after
Tosh and they're like isn't workaholics
Tuesdays 10:00 p.m. like no no detective
Google me and I'm like okay so you got a
lap dance from a shark they just like
take them very matter-of-factly and in
my head I'm thinking my parents are dead
right they're not taking the zealand
hitch squad has already taken care of
exactly exactly but they made it through
okay no they're gone
[Laughter]